then in 2012 an investigative reporter
forces the US government to release
documents which reveal the Chesapeake
Bay's dark history documents are
Declassified by the US Army and the
United States government that show in
this area of the Chesapeake Bay there
were experiments on US soldiers 7,000 of
which were subjected to the most bizarre
experimentation the declassified
documents contain information about
Edgewood Arsenal a large military
installation 43 miles to the north of
the new island between 1948 and 1975 it
was the center of a secret US Army
program dubbed Operation delirium
operation delirium was a u.s. department
of defense program to test chemical
agents on our own troops and see what
happened enlisted volunteers were asked
to take part in a carefully controlled
test each of the volunteers received a
minor dose of the psycho chemical in
coffee it was kept undercover because of
course they knew you know look these are
human experiments just a small quantity
of LSD is sufficient to upset the normal
physical and emotional behavior pattern
they no longer behave like well
disciplined troops the drugs they used
range from LSD to tear gas to nerve
agents could you imagine if today
somebody found out that the US
government is involved in experimenting
on the people that are defending their
nation that they're actually using them
for chemical experimentation the agent
produced the beer irritation of the eyes
nose broken lung heavy labored breathing
and searing chest pain the Chesapeake
Bay Island raises fears that the US
military is once again experimenting on
its own troops we do know that today the
US government is developing drugs that
they hope will make US soldiers sort of
superhuman fighting machines that will
make them for example not need so much
sleep not need to eat not feel as much
fear if I went out and rented a boat and
took that boat right up to the island
and put it ashore then got up and
started to walk around would no one care
would I be greeted only by flocks of
birds or would I be greeted with men
carrying black rifles and uniform that
would want to know what the hell I was
doing there